this is episode 181 of congratulations
[Music]
all right dude all right
and i already made a mistake dude i
[ __ ] google
every time i go to google a counter
uh timer and i don't click stopwatch i
click timer and i click timer
and it goes ah [ __ ] what is it a
stopwatch or a [ __ ] timer dude
stop watch because i want to know how
long i'm doing but i put timer and timer
counts down
ah yes from five minutes it starts from
five minutes dude which is great we're
not gonna do a five minute podcast
uh we're not gonna do a five minute peak
cast we're gonna do a [ __ ] hour long
p
cast if you're on patreon and if you're
not then you're going to get the uh
not the extended version and uh you know
that's just how it's going to be
so this meme all day guess i'll die now
or the ch
or the the chick that's like this with
the blue shirt
um already [ __ ] have ivan get rid of
already gave him some work to put that
[ __ ] picture in the upper corner
um so that's how we do it man we [ __ ]
we work hard wow wow dude my phone just
clinked and it made a [ __ ] ka-ching
sound so you know i'm an [ __ ]
um that uh so i put it on silent and
we're g and we're good we're good to go
and we're and uh so i put it on timer
and it went down so i had to google
stopwatch i never know what what the
difference between this timer or
stopwatch is
it doesn't matter when i work out i do
it in intervals
and my knee hurts because of that does
many hurt yes
dude am i sweaty yes because it's
getting warmer in california yes and i
didn't adjust the heat the way the heat
or the air the way i wanted to on the
[ __ ]
bottom level yes so is it too hot yes
it's a fine
yeah that's fine but you know i'm gonna
have
a lot of [ __ ] beads
slowly cascading down my [ __ ]
moguls my [ __ ] back is a ski slope
dude
i you know i don't know why you listen
to this podcast and i don't know why
i yeah i don't know why i'm still doing
it but i'm doing it and uh
i [ __ ] i thank you for listening um
but yeah i started a new workout kind of
plan uh
this guy in montreal is is uh has been
[ __ ] on my case
john chamber shout out to him i like him
a lot uh
dude and i work out and i thought i was
good at working out and guess what i'm
not dude the second you get
somebody helping you to work out you
just realize you're a [ __ ]
doormat you're just a piece of [ __ ] like
you could move around
weights all day by yourself
and it isn't as hard as like a 25-minute
session from some guy
that just like studies nutrition and
also
[ __ ] uh weightlifting
and it's just i i wanted to i wanted to
die
uh i wan and i was gasping for air
i was gasping for [ __ ] air like adam
west when the penguin just goes
and [ __ ] puts the the the gas on them
the green gas
it's green in that [ __ ] show dude in
batman in the old show batman
it's green dude so we all knew it was
coming out of the umbrella
just [ __ ] i don't like that when the
shows do that when it's like
like everyone's ringer is always on just
so you know
at home they're getting a phone call
when it's like we're not idiots
nobody's ringer is ever on i've never
heard i haven't heard a ringer in like
three years
and this and when you do everyone is
like oh that's the [ __ ]
and everyone on every show is just like
oh hold on i'm getting a phone call it's
like dude
come on get it together make it [ __ ]
more real
snap back to reality oops we're going
through the bumps it goes gravity
goes to nabity um
yeah so it's just like all right
okay tv show it's just like okay tv show
if that's what you're gonna do i'll
still watch it
i'm not gonna stand for anything i'll
just keep watching
shows dude shows room it takes a show a
long time for me to piss me off
i mean it it'll it'll get me going but
then i'll just be like all right i'll
just keep watching [ __ ] it
i'll just be like oh come on this is me
watching every show oh come on dude
really
all right well let's just see what
happens the next scene just for [ __ ]
eight seasons
eight whole seasons oh all right dude
really well hold on don't change it
let's just see what happens the next
the next scene um
yeah so i've been watching that
undercover billionaire show
which just by the way i played it just
because of what it's called
it's so hilarious that the shows
are all like million dollar matchmaker
millionaire
so i want to be a millionaire so i want
to [ __ ] marry a millionaire
are you a millionaire let's all be
millionaires there's 900 shows with the
[ __ ] [ __ ] thing
millionaire in it and then some jackass
show
just comes along and it's called
undercover
billionaire like some billionaire was
like
oh i just i don't give a [ __ ] i'll just
be on tv the guy's worth [ __ ] two
something billion dollars
and he decides to go to erie
pennsylvania
don't go where everything's just brown
and green and gray
and there's so many [ __ ] water tanks
and [ __ ]
dude i gotta be an author and just write
about erie pennsylvania and just write
yeah it was brown and gray and green a
lot and and
and [ __ ] there were so many water
tanks all around
jimmy was walking down the street and he
was cold as [ __ ] because it's always
cold there
why is it called eerie he thought
shouldn't be called eerie because eerie
is a [ __ ] negative connotation and
they're wondering and everyone in erie
wonders why it's down in the dumps
they're still trying to rebuild anyway
jimmy was walking down the street
[Laughter]
worst book ever dude but best book ever
um
so yeah so he goes to erie with a
hundred dollars
no contacts in his phone and just shows
up
and in 90 days 90 days
he's gonna [ __ ] make a million dollar
company
guess if he's five five or not
he's five five dude he's so short and of
course he is
because no guy who's six two or above is
just gonna be like
i got something to prove uh
yeah so he comes out and he sleeps in
his car dude the guy's worth over two
billion dollars that's too much
dude if i was worth two billion dollars
i'd keep it all
and i'd die with it i wouldn't tell
anybody about it
um no but uh so he so we we
so we watch and he's got like nine you
know five kids or something
and kristen is next to me and as soon as
the show starts she's like that's like
really responsible for him to like leave
for 90 days and he's got like two young
kids and i'm just like just
are we watching it or not
and um so we watch it and he's five five
and he comes out and he's just like
so i left everywhere to come here to
erie pennsylvania
with a hundred dollars no contacts and i
changed my last name so nobody knows who
i
am everything's a show now
everything is a [ __ ] show now i'm not
gonna eat bread for nine days
tune in to tbs
let's see if i can go let's see if i can
go 900 years without walking
without walking i'm just going to crawl
everywhere i'm going to do an army crawl
everywhere
on the next episode of crawling
oh it [ __ ] hurts on my torso
on the learning chat it's always the
learning channel hey
what the [ __ ] are we learning dude hey
learning channel
what the [ __ ] are we learning anymore
dude it's just like
what's that one midgetville or whatever
the [ __ ] it is
tiny guys in tiny houses i don't know
it's like what are they doing
the learning channel [ __ ] off dude what
what are you talk what are we learning
uh the learning chat
90 day fee isn't that on [ __ ] 98
fiance isn't that on the learning
channel
what the [ __ ] are we learning what are
we learning how big of a jackass
not to be yes dude these guys are just
like
troglodytes or the female is a
troglodyte and then the guy or the
female is from the other country and he
comes in and he's just like
gaston and [ __ ] dressed up with one of
those [ __ ] coffee filter neck neck
things that
gestan wears hello i'll marry you
are you sure it's not cause you wanna
live in los
in america
no i love you okay can we have sex
no no no i'm a virgin and i'll be that
way until i get my citizenship
um but that's the thing and i know what
that feels like too when you just want
it to work so
the [ __ ] the
the the hopefulness of it is just
come on dude it's like when you're when
you watch that old press your luck show
and they're just like no means no ways
no emmys no i missed the women's it's so
[ __ ] how they always do it no emmy's
noams the whammies and women's and
then oh we got a whammy you hope for the
nowhere me so much but the [ __ ]
whammy comes every time
and the way me in this case is he
doesn't love you
because you're portly and you're [ __ ]
60 and he's 22.
um
but uh yeah so 90 day fiance don't don't
be on that show but everyone just wants
to be famous you know
uh so this guy's a billionaire and he
goes to erie pennsylvania and tries to
and i didn't [ __ ]
do it and i watched five episodes with
my fiance
with my 600-day fiance
and uh because covet happened and
everything else
and um and dude
we watched five episodes and i went to
sleepies and then i woke up and i went
to go get a coffee and i came back
five o'clock rolls around she's like i
finished our show and i'm like
how there's [ __ ] 20 episodes and
she's like i just want 17 and 18. [ __ ]
it
and i said well how'd you you just
skipped and she she literally said
i don't know and i said we mean oh no
did you watch all of them or not she's
like i i don't know i just ended
and i'm like oh she's not gonna [ __ ]
be even i don't even
so now we got to watch a new [ __ ]
show dude
uh when you're when you're when you're
when your fiance watches the end of a
show that you just
[ __ ] spent five hours on guess i'll
die now
dude wow anyway um
so yeah so we watched [ __ ] undercover
billionaire dude wow i wish there was a
show called [ __ ]
undercover trillionaire and it was a guy
who was worth a trillion dollars and he
just came in
and he floated in with on a jet pack
or on those [ __ ] water things that
don't work where you where you go in the
water
and then they squirt you up like
nine feet for two seconds and then you
fall on your neck and hurt yourself
dude those those talk about so [ __ ]
those water thing where you do in the
ocean or the lake
where you hook on your feet first of all
those are way too big
that's the whole thing where it's like i
don't invent it until it's better
do you know what i'm talking about like
don't invent the [ __ ] thing till it's
better
i feel that way about the internet half
the time i'm like if it doesn't work
don't have it if i'm in a [ __ ] coffee
shop and
and i'm like and i'm like do you guys
have wi-fi
and they're always like yeah but it's
not you know what stop
do you have it or not does it work don't
have it
if it works have it do you know what i'm
talking about
yeah it's to every coffee shop i go do
you have wi-fi yeah but you have to the
thing
oh you know what stop dude stop
you have to sign into the portal and
then the boy then you need it here let
me write it down
why do you have [ __ ] things that you
give out you have to write it to here
it's a weird
here it's a weird password and it's case
sensitive oh for [ __ ] sake dude i'm
just using g
network or whatever the hell it's called
41. um
i'm just using g network it sounds like
a rap group in 2001.
um oh man me and my friend used to do
the
pimp song that's the only song you can't
[ __ ] hum
or the [ __ ] g-unit one
the
can't even [ __ ] hum it my uncle once
said that
rap's the only music you can't hum think
about it every six months
uh anyway dude
it is what it is calvin's doing this
thing where
we when we drink we'll go like come on
calvin's my son for those of you that
don't know but i will go like come on
drink ah you drink
we'll do that like you know we're in a
pepsi commercial and uh
so he does it now he he just goes he'll
drink it
and then he'll like you know every sip
like a toddler takes is just like
okay i think i remember this i think i
remember how it goes down but let me
just make sure that everything's cool
my eyes are watering a little bit all
good
okay and then he'll do it
it's so funny it'll he'll just like
he'll have to reboot after every sip
he'll drink he'll drink and then he'll
just act like someone's spraying his
face with a water gun for a little bit
he's just like
it's like you don't have to forcibly do
ah you can it's just supposed to be
refreshing kid
and so he does it but now he just thinks
it means drink
and so every anytime i'm drinking
anything he'll just point to it and i'll
go
whether it's a bottle or a cup or a jug
or whatever the [ __ ] it is
and i'm just and i'll be drinking like
coffee like cold brew
or his mom will be drinking uh my fiance
i'll be drinking a [ __ ]
uh what is it a margarita
and we're just like no this is for daddy
no it's for daddy and he'll go
and i'm just like it's coffee you're
going to be up all night
it's or it's like lacroix and i know the
bubbles he can't even barely
when he drinks water looks like zybal's
gonna pop out of his head
and so i'm like all right fine today i
was just like okay here here's lacroix
and i gave it to him and he just goes
and i'm like are you gonna are you gonna
make it through this or what he's just
like
and then at the end he just looked at me
after a while and he goes
dude it's so [ __ ] funny and fun to
have a kid
like he just is hilarious
kids are hilarious you know
god he's so funny love the [ __ ]
uh i gotta get him to [ __ ] start
working out soon man
the worst thing that the thing that he
the one of the most annoying things
about a baby
is or a toddler is they don't like i
don't know if they like don't remember
or they just don't give a [ __ ] which
i like if they don't give a [ __ ] but
when you like when you're wiping their
face
they act like they act like you're
trying to like
suffocate them you know they act like
they're trying to like
and you're just like just you got you
have one thing here and they're just
and it's like dude you do you remember
that this just takes [ __ ] four
seconds dude
if you just relax sit the [ __ ] tight
you got milk all over you from
you've got milk all over your face all
it takes is a little dab or two and if i
miss it i come back and i dab another
and they're just like i'm not hey
and you're and it's just taking long do
you remember
from lunch i literally left the [ __ ]
pesto on the ravioli on your chin
because it's so annoying no no
[Music]
no
he's just and you're like all right then
have a messy face dude
and then if you i post you on my
instagram story or somebody sees you
then people just think that we're a
dirty family
great we're a dirty family now [ __ ] it
we're a dirty family
dude he bought something on the apple tv
today
like legit i know people like always
joke and lie about that to make it funny
but straight up cali grabbed the
apple remote which is the worst remote
on the [ __ ] planet
okay because it's the size of a stamp
like dude that's one of those things
that i don't need to be so small
it's a remote control we lose it anyway
remember the universal remotes
when it was like what do you want to
watch you want to watch mr belvedere
great let me play it
remember the universal remotes when the
[ __ ] [ __ ] was when
each button was as big as your hand
those were so big that's
that's one of those things where i said
don't invent until it works those
universal remotes
the apple remotes need to be bigger
anyway my my kids got it and he's
crawling all over creation
i don't even know where the [ __ ] and
he's got it and i see the apple tv just
it goes to that page where all of the
different applications are open and i'm
just like is this a computer now
hey kid i'm a computer
bro that old gi joe [ __ ] hey kid i'm a
computer
um i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] on ebon's
world anyway
he um he he [ __ ] grab it does it and
i'm just like you know what dude i'm
just gonna let you have the remote what
are you gonna do break it and then he
just goes
blink blink and then it just signs it it
just
uh plays the thing and i'm like oh i
have apple tv it's fine
and then i'm going number two and i
check my emails because that's the only
time i ever check my emails and i look
and it's like thanks for your purchase
of the [ __ ] apple tv i'm like he
[ __ ] bought it i thought i had apple
tv
i only have apple tv on the other on the
other [ __ ]
account or something i don't know how
many accounts i don't understand really
what happened but i do know that he
bought something
and here's the [ __ ] kicker dude
because he
he just played it i started watching it
and i'm just like ah this is kind of
good now i'm gonna [ __ ]
watch it thing i gotta buy the whole
goddamn thing
this kid works for apple tv
he's got his dirty face just ah boom
boom boom boom boom playing
some [ __ ] with that girl from
the jumanji the new jumanji
she's such a girl uh an actress that
would have a show on apple tv it's
unbelievable
the the one with the she's in jumanji
and also she
plays somebody in one of them x-men
shows or something
41. dude i was on my discord chat
earlier and someone was like
i'm gonna i'm gonna what'd they say
what's your favorite star wars and i was
just like
um
i [ __ ] anyway wiping a baby's mouth
takes so [ __ ] long
but we love him so much i said it a
little bit the other day i forgot to
finish talking about it on my last
pocket but we love him so much he's
gonna have a complex dude
we're just like we love i mean we i
don't know
like we tell him we love him so much
that he's just like
yeah okay i'll play with i'm gonna play
and um
i feel like this kid is just gonna grow
up and you know how i said i walk into
rooms and i just assume everyone hates
me he's going to have the opposite he's
going to walk in the room and just be
like
where are my presents
where where are my presents
why are you not on your knees for me and
playing with me
um why are you not on your knees doing
things for me
um so yeah
i don't know man we love him
i love being a dad dude being a dad
[ __ ] rips dude
being the dad [ __ ] rips
renner took me out um so yeah so
oh i got you know what i haven't done
for a while man
is uh looked at youtube videos and i
don't
a lot of you guys are hitting me up on
my patreon telling me
patreon.com uh slash crystalia
i gotta watch youtube videos so i'm
gonna [ __ ] watch some youtube videos
and some of these are [ __ ] sent from
you guys
but also other ones that i like a lot
now
here's the thing i [ __ ] clicked out
of it
oh [ __ ] yeah dude i clicked out of it oh
yes dude it's gone dude before i sat
down
i got four [ __ ] things put them on
four different pages
and i've clicked out of it you know why
i clicked out of it
because i [ __ ] the stopwatch thing
was on it the timer was on it and i
clicked out of the whole thing and now
the only thing that's up
is a stopwatch and that doesn't even
matter hey yeah dude
i had four [ __ ] pages clicked on and
i don't have any one of them
yes man dude i you know what [ __ ] it
i don't dude god how do i have a
[ __ ] show that people listen to i
don't know
but anyway the i you know i could i
could pull it up because this one was so
good to me man
um youtube let's go to youtube how many
got any good youtubes lately um
that was the doorman at my brother's
building got any new got any good
youtubes lately
nah like it's candy um
what is it not gay no more this [ __ ]
thing
man i can't remember how i saw it
somebody sent it to me oh somebody sent
it to me
do you believe okay dude lord tonight
first of all black preacher and he said
lord
um said lord
do you believe the lord
there's a d he doesn't give a [ __ ] why
would he
um he's preacher preachers don't give a
[ __ ] you know what i'm talking about
they do everything for the lord and have
a jet
these these television and they're
they're just like give money to the
homeless
boom in their jet um
this is this is from silly funny videos
okay you know try harder
silly funny videos try harder with the
account name anyway um
young gay man is delivered from
homosexuality and party dances
oh so foreign party dancing dancing is
fine anyway um
do you guys party dancing or what
tonight you guys party dancing tonight
or you just
um so this [ __ ]
do you believe that the lord tonight
has set you free yes sir
okay do you believe that the lord
tonight is has set you free and then the
guy just goes without hesitation which
is what i
[ __ ] love about this [ __ ] he just
says
yes sir dude there is no second guessing
and that is because
the preacher knows how to talk
and knows his [ __ ] this preacher is the
mentalist
this preacher tells you how to feel and
the dude is just like
yes sir i i don't have a mind no more
so i ain't got no mind no more so
shoot from the hip so he just goes
do you believe the lord has set you and
on
the back end of him talking yes sir
nodded so hard his head almost lopped
off now
we continue to tell those people
now turn around and tell those people
and this is the best because the guy
goes to grab the microphone
and then the preacher has something else
to say and the guy goes to grab the
microphone and misses
e is a [ __ ] and um
i'm not oh
wow he grabs the microphone phone the
first thing he does is
so good dude i used to have a spanish
teacher that was named mr takame
and he would he would breathe so much it
was unbelievable it was
like dude how many [ __ ] lungs do you
have
he would just be like hello muchachos
baseball i'm gay no more
oh dude this is the best right here well
let's start it over because if you
really gotta
ramp it up when you ramp it up there's a
big pay payoff dude so he just
turn around and tell those people
i i also is so not specific dude turn
around and tell those people
tell them and the guy just grabs the
microphone literally could have said
anything
um i am sand
so uh
wow dude he just the
enthusiasm he goes
i'm not gay no more i am delivered
and he says delivered
the lord delivered him
wow that is just
i'm not gay no more i am delivered
wow he felt it dude i love
when people feel lies
i love when a guy gets fired and says oh
this best thing ever happened to me
well just start a new life
delivered eyes rolled back in his head
when he said it
i'm not gay no more i am delivered
cool let's keep going i don't like me oh
screaming it dude or i am delivered
i don't like men no more oh
my god dude
[Laughter]
i don't like mans no more
lost credibility when you made
men even more plural
i don't like mans no more it looked like
he
felt himself so hard that he
i'm shocked he didn't do this afterwards
this guy wants to believe it so badly
that he's yelling it's
so hard i don't like
men's no more i said i like women
wow i don't like friends didn't say it
didn't say it and then he says i said i
like women
and as he's saying it
he turns around and faces
the back
lying
hey you turned around
and faced the back
you're lying
hello officer why did you pull me over
do you not know why do you know how fast
you were going
all right honestly i have no idea
why'd you turn around oh i'm lying
i mean dude he turned around that's the
best also guess if he's wearing a bow
tie or not
oh you guessed right guess if he's got a
paisley blazer on you guessed right
oh wow dude i did not know he did that i
don't think i watched this whole thing i
actually don't even know if i
i thought i like women
wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
put his face in titties you know um so
anyway motorboating um
i'm not gay screaming screaming so loud
has a microphone the guys on stage with
him are just like
i don't uh we thought we thought this
was
we thought he was paralyzed and we were
going to help him stand
i would not date a man telling himself i
would not
carry a purse telling himself not put on
makeup
tell himself
so not sure what he is going to say dude
also went way further into it
like talking about how he's not gay and
then immediately we got
a hint that he also dresses like a woman
you know
i will not carry a purse i will not put
on makeup
okay that's fine dude that's all good
and then he says i will love a woman
like he's one of those [ __ ]
saudi arabian guys that comment on on
instagram girls pictures
picture of bob's please um
i will i will love
a woman wow so not sure what he's going
to say
listen y'all praise god with him
hold on somebody you know it's
[ __ ] it's funny but it's also like
here's the thing
i think two years ago i would have just
thought this was funny
but just because like i'm
i'm like really trying to like
understand myself
like everybody's got their [ __ ] you know
everybody's got their [ __ ]
that they're that they're that they're
trying to [ __ ] work through
and it just it just is sad that this guy
thinks that he
it's sad to me this video because like
dude if he's gay
[ __ ] be gay and let's just chill man
you don't have to like a women
you know you don't have to have the
[ __ ] lord delivered you
just [ __ ] be gay be so gay dude put
on makeup
wear a purse rock that [ __ ]
you know let's see the comments
someone writes i said i like women's
women's women's women's blah blah blah
blah blah
wow
i mean dude it's just uh well
i hope that that dude is just out there
living with a guy and loving it uh
this is another video this was sent by a
guy on my patreon
that calls himself bags dentless
so doesn't get the jargon but uh
anyway well if you find yourself stuck
trying to move around on the ice many
people say you should
kind of walk like a penguin dude i just
you know what i don't even want to watch
this [ __ ]
well now we'll watch it this guy dude
it's just the whitest guy of all time
if you find yourself walking the block
like it or not but it's
10 news reporter coulter and they're
teaching you how to walk on ice
dude what about how everyone's dying
news
you really that short on news
everyone's dying everyone's getting beat
up
no matter what race you are you're
getting beat up no matter what
where you are in the world so many of
your friends died
and these guys are like
walking on ice is actually something
that we can tell you about tonight uh
and they say to walk like a penguin
okay you're just gonna stride on it to
work and come down to this end
walking on an icy surface like a
sidewalk or park dude oh [ __ ] the
news dude there's always the guy who
introduces it and then there's a guy
with the voice over
that has to be higher than the news guy
you know what i'm talking about
they say while you're walking on the ice
to walk like a peg wetter that's what it
is how do but we're
checking with johnny johnson and we're
gonna know what's going on here
and then it cuts to a guy in the field
and the voiceover is like
they say when you're walking on ice
walking on ice safely is actually it's
literally what happened here
you're just gonna stride on it to work
and come down to this end walking on an
icy surface like a sidewalk or park like
what is this guy talking like this for
just [ __ ] be regular when i wanna do
the news
and i just want to be like yeah it's
going to [ __ ] rain over here and
a guy got beat up in huntington beach
but he [ __ ] kind of deserved it
hey i'm here i'm crystal lee i'm live at
huntington beach where a guy got [ __ ]
kicked in
he was at a pizza place and uh he just
kind of [ __ ] i don't know man
this guy came through what happened
uh yeah he came in my my uh my pizza
place
and basically he was he was um
acting all jittery i thought he was on
drugs and i had to kick him out and uh
he tried to fight me and i punch him in
the face all right there you have it
what else back to you or whatever
i i don't like the whole
thing you think dude the the [ __ ] that
we're pouring money into
there's a [ __ ] mechanism dude
it cuts to for those of you listening to
this it cuts to
a whole device that's like uh uh
one of those it looks like monkey bars
and then a
tether coming down from it and then a
guy's got a vest attached to the tether
and then there's like a plank of ice
under it and he's hooked into the
[ __ ]
mechanism and he's like trying to walk
on ice dude
this is like millions of dollars
just if if you fall on ice
get up you don't
who's to learn who watched this
whose life did this save
put the money in [ __ ] cancer
everyone's getting that
and some guy's just walking on ice like
a like a like a [ __ ]
strapped in under his legs he's all
bunched up and [ __ ] so what you're going
to do is
real biodynamic slip simulator bio what
the [ __ ]
biodynamic slip simulator real
biodynamics what is this called
this [ __ ] waste of money
industrial biodynamics slip simulator
industrial biodynamic
slip simulator hey if you fall on ice
you
[ __ ] up okay that's it dude my uncle
fell on ice
hit his head so bad got a concussion
that's on him man
that's on him he hurt his back for
[ __ ] three weeks
that's on him and if i fell on ice
that's on me
you think i would [ __ ] be like oh i
wish i saw this [ __ ] thing on
wsls10 news
evening news so i would know how to walk
also
it's uneven ice is not even and this
[ __ ] is like a sheet of like
it's like dude what are we the [ __ ]
kings or whatever is that even a [ __ ]
hockey team anymore
what are we the hurricanes probably as a
team
what are we the [ __ ] oilers
uh [ __ ] sports teams dude
the browns is a team you know like what
try harder
it's football i know i know i know i'm
joking okay
[Music]
walking normally this look you know what
this mechanism looks like when when like
tv with when movies that don't have
enough budget like show someone hang
themselves
it's like all the whole backpack is on
and you're like you ever see the movie
where the guy hangs himself and then you
know the budget was bad because the guy
if you hang yourself it's like that you
know but the [ __ ]
in low budget movies he's got like oh
and he's just like
and you're like oh he's got the pack on
he took me out of it
look his shoulders are touching his ears
that wouldn't happen
struggled to keep my balance and made
the mistake of using my
arms look at this the problem with that
is we get stiff
so as you start to slip we start to do
this kind of motion
and that really enhances that slip and
this guy is studying people slipping
industrial biodynamics president john
hager says marching with short flat
steps
is the best technique marching with
short flat steps is the best technique
dude
just let me fall imagine
just like oh hold on it looks slippery
like you're one of those monkeys with
the symbols the wind up hold on dude
they say takes you on a date hey
let me just i'm gonna you know what to
do right sweetheart
what i know it's our first date but i
might as well tell you
this is icy we gotta walk like this
completely dry um
uh yeah dude just fall you know i don't
want to see [ __ ] like this
it's called best technique to use when
walking on ice no
to technique you know just that has to
like it's not bad mitten
there is a guy on oh by the way
salt bae you're done dude thanks
you're done
this guy made [ __ ] eight billion
dollars off of doing this
more power to him dude i'm in love with
him actually hey
is he in costume or is that his face
also you know he's [ __ ] you know he's
5'4
and that's it that's all i have to say
about that and why is he dressed like a
[ __ ] johnny depp character in 1994
always
and that is the truth and dude the new
[ __ ] that he does on the thing
he just goes wow do it
stick to just salting your elbow man
um yeah so i i got a guy who
did the um i found a guy
and i've been i've been waiting to talk
about this guy
uh it was sent to me by my buddy cannon
king
and he is on
he had some followers when i first found
out about him when canon showed me
but i found
he's been gaining popularity now and i'm
like i gotta [ __ ] do the podcast
because i want to talk about him
this guy is my favorite person dude
his name is white claw gabe
now let's bring this guy up
instagram on instagram i know he's i
think he's bigger on tick tock
but this guy dude what was the first one
i saw of his
i'm just gonna play a random one it's so
great what this guy's doing
here we go
[ __ ] friday going from my [ __ ]
daily walk and [ __ ] man
[ __ ] last night was a blast i feel
[ __ ] little [ __ ] tired right now
at least i'm going for a [ __ ] daily
walk get up your lazy bums take your
[ __ ] walk
friday yeah it's the weekend baby [ __ ]
it's nothing like friday friday and
saturday and sunday who deserves friday
saturday and sunday me
[ __ ] friday doesn't feel like friday
friday feels like saturday for me
okay just doing my like you know
hey dude figure out what you're gonna
say first uh
hey it's [ __ ] friday so many [ __ ]
dude
this is great anything you click on is
amazing watch here's a random one
it's saturday i gotta go to the studio
and ballin baby
wow first of all dude the first one
started with it's friday [ __ ] and then
this
this one which is like seven videos
after he says hey it's saturday baby
[ __ ]
dude so many videos okay [ __ ] yeah
i got a ball at the studio yeah i gotta
make some [ __ ] money at the studio
bowling baby yeah
[ __ ] for for fight night
so unsure what it seems like for the
fight nights and steaks [ __ ]
i gotta get to the studio and [ __ ]
bomb
what's up [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] going to the studio
saturday i mean dude cut himself off
[ __ ] gonna have sticks tonight [ __ ]
always thinking everything's a problem
um always realize always remembering
something oh this one's good here
this one's good god damn it [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] man [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] sunny said nothing so far
[ __ ]
wow said absolutely nothing so far it's
been lindy go [ __ ] yourself there we go
let it get up maybe i gotta get up
go to work go to school [ __ ]
[ __ ] monday i hate it hate it man
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
man it's [ __ ] monday
this guy oh my god i could watch this
all day i don't give a [ __ ] here's the
thing man
some people are like okay it's funny
whatever like
move on dude i want to watch this guy
all day you don't get it you don't get
it
i want to hang out with this guy this
guy's my new jackson human
i want to hang out with this guy and
chill with him man
the guy's into it ah baby happy monday
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] hey monday go [ __ ]
yourself if you gotta go to work or
girls go hang money for go [ __ ] yourself
i just done going to the bathroom [ __ ]
and i'm going to show you something baby
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
hey monday go [ __ ] yourself [ __ ]
the toilet baby wow yeah hey monday
go [ __ ] yourself amazing pay off the
toilet baby
yeah what an amazing payoff hey i'm
gonna show you something
[ __ ] baby yeah [ __ ] uh hey monday i'm
here i'm gonna show you oh [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm
gonna show you something baby and then
just takes toilet paper it puts it in
the toilet and flushes it yeah
monday [ __ ] you
such a good payoff dude that was better
honestly
than the [ __ ] avengers movie when he
goes and
everyone faded away that shit's better
he's the might he's the avenger
white claw gave the avenger um
this guy's a riot you gotta follow this
[ __ ] dude
he's got 16 000 followers he had like 9
000 when i first saw
him oh he's on cameo dude i'm gonna get
a cameo from him 100 no doubt
um anyway anyway that's it that's it i'm
done
uh hey you guys sign up for my patreon
patreon.com
slash crystalia uh there's two tiers
there check it all out
that's how you support the show there's
also some [ __ ] merch out
we got that summertime merch and i'm rip
roaring in it dude i wear the life rip
shirt and the life rips hoodie
and i'm walking out styling dude i love
making my own clothes and wearing them
shits man
uh you guys are great thanks very much
uh and dude if you support the show
thank you it truly means a lot love you
guys bye
[Music]
you